la crise lakovic 19 a été profitable
pour l'entreprise québécoise qui a
développé l'espace ue que c'est une
plateforme d'événements virtuels
interactifs entreprises s'est associé à
solotech il va ouvrir quatre nouveaux
espaces en septembre à los angelès new
york nashville et au royaume uni avec
nous benoît frenette et les fondateurs
de l'entreprise bonsoir monsieur
fredette
bonjour enchanté c'est pas tout le monde
qui connaît le concept expliquez vous ce
que c'est exactement l'espace [ __ ] el
espacio pas en fait une façon
alternative de pouvoir assister à des
spectacles
donc c'est un concept qu'on avait
commencé à débuter le bien avant la
pandémie avec la vision de pouvoir
donner une chance à plus de gens
d'assister le don que ça arrive que des
fois les spectacles ne viennent pas
toujours dans certaines villes
ça arrive que des fois les gens manquent
les spectacles ou trouve pas de gardien
no ainsi de suite donc on voulait
trouver une façon alternative que les
gens puissent regarder en ligne
facilement acheter un accès au spectacle
et puis on a voulu ajouter le vraiment
quelque chose de particulier donc donner
la chance aux gens de pouvoir se
retrouver sur scène y avoir une
interaction en direct avec l'artiste
donc ça c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'on a développé un point de vue
technologique
donc si je comprends bien on est assez
dans le confort de fonds chez soi dans
son salon et on regarde le spectacle
d'un humoriste qu'on aime par exemple
c'est ça quand vous voyez c'est exact
donc tout est simple à partir de la même
plateforme sur l'application youku sur
le site web bio point ap les gens
peuvent acheter l'accès au spectacle le
visionner et pendant qu'ils visionnent
s'ils sont choisis vont avoir l'option
d'un vide accepter ou décliner une
invitation à se rejoindre sur scène
et puis bon les gens qui font la
production et la régie sur scène d'un
peuvent contrôler et qui est en mesure
d'avoir les interactions avec l'artiste
donc si c'est vraiment plus tôt immersif
l'oeil et intérêts aux mêmes qui
possible lorsqu'on assiste parfois
physiquement confère vous travaillé de
concert justement avec votre ami louis
morissette dans ce projet là comment
l'idée vous aimez bien en fait comme
comme je l'expliquais c'est quelque
chose qu'on a travaillé depuis plusieurs
années les chioukhs et c'est venu
surtout des artistes eux mêmes des
artisans
il nous disait coûté faire la tournée
c'est difficile c'est beaucoup de
déplacements de voyagement
c'est dur mentalement physiquement mais
aussi pour les familles des artistes
puis on a aussi les artistes en début de
carrière qui pour eux ceci très coûteux
le partir en tournée il faut l'expliquer
donc si c'est pas facile pour les
nouveaux artistes de partir un groupe de
fans à travers le monde et partir en
tournée c'est pas tout le monde qui peut
se l'offrir donc ces moyens là ça permet
à des gens exemple on pense à l'islam en
fait ces produits exemple une nouvelle
artiste
il ya quelques semaines l'espace ou pas
montréal a été capable de rejoindre des
gens au royaume uni aux états unis en
france donc c'est vraiment parti de là
et puis louis bon quelqu'un que j'ai
énormément de respect et qui fait de la
très très bonne production
c'est vrai qu'on avait cet outil là dans
l'entreprise on prévoyait le l'ancien au
départ à la fin de cette année ou au
début de l'année prochaine et il m'a
contacté et m'a dit benoît je pourrais
loupé le déploiement la technologie et à
compléter avant la coved mais la
pandémie a certainement une zone forcer
la main à le lancer plus rapidement donc
on a dû accélérer la commercialisation
puis oui on a vu certaines opportunités
d'affaires mais faut le dire on a
surtout vu c'est très triste de voir ce
qui arrive à l'industrie présentement on
a vu une chance d'aider les artisans les
techniciens tous les gens qui
travaillent donc de mettre en branle et
lui est vraiment l'opérateur c'est juste
pour comprendre monsieur fraude est ça
leur permet de monétiser leurs et ils
touchent des revenus là c'est une façon
virtuelle de faire de l'argent avec leur
art qu'ils n'ont pas en public en ce
moment oui non exactement donc les
recettes de vendre vont directement à
l'artiste le donc chaque artiste peut
s'auto produire d'une certaine façon et
le fait d'avoir un espacio dédié dans
certains grands centres comme exemple
montréal et le premier ça permet
d'amortir les coûts de production sur
plusieurs artistes de rands soit
beaucoup plus abordable donc c'est
seulement de la fin oui
ouais quand les événements publics vont
reprendre
monsieur freud est est ce que l'espace
ue va rester encore aussi pertinents ben
je crois que oui pascal abbas avait été
développé en complément donc comme je
l'expliquais c'était les écrans
convoyait s'ajouter vers la fin des
tournées donc pour les gens comme de
comme le disait qu'ils ont peut-être
manqué un spectacle où donc on voyait
vraiment un mode hybride bon c'est
certain qu'en temps de pandémie ça
devient une base d'un point d'ancrage
assez important mais par la suite on
pense que c'est vraiment un modèle qui
qui va continuer d'évoluer et qui va
définitivement duré en tout cas c'est
recherché parce que vous venez de signer
des enfants nous est en expansion s'est
il nous reste très peu de temps le maire
vous avez des plans l'international oui
ben écoutez c'est la demande a été leur
incroyable en étant on va planifier pour
faire plus mais spectacle selon la
demande cette année donc oui puis on a
ouvert les centres comme l'un mentionné
los angeles new york nashville et au
royaume uni
et depuis qu'on a annoncé cela il ya
déjà deux jours la demande continue pour
d'autres centres donc on est excité en
eau bien je vous fais mon truc c'est
merci beaucoup d'avoir été là monsieur
fredette
merci à vous bonne soirée à vous